there's a larger spiritual and energetic
component to this that we definitely do
not understand but but it's interesting
because you just mentioned that there is
these kind of individuals are calling
for the same thing throughout many
different years and many different
decades I I absolutely agree with you
what are they calling for exactly how
would you explain that to the kind of
Normie Kyle and Karen out there what are
they calling for what's the what's their
goal I think the elite ideology nowadays
is wedded to a form of extreme Darwinism
where there's a social Darwin darwinian
attitude that if you are in power you
have the right to be in power and that
goes along with the the belief that
actually goes back to Plato and the
Republic that the human population has
to be kept at a certain level for the
Ideal Balance Plato's whole system was
based on Pythagoras's number mysticism
so there's a lot of hoodoo in that but
what what today's Elite have borrowed or
taken from Plato is the idea of
dialectics and part of dialectics is
that you have to do evil and good at the
same time time yeah he also believed in
problem reaction Solution that's where a
lot of the larger kind of uh
um implementation of a lot of different
programs that they do Plato thinks that
Society should be controlled by a secret
society that lies to the public it's
called The Noble lie and it's a it's a
loose kind of technocratic model even
though he didn't believe it they didn't
know about technology per se and the way
that we do
in Plato's Republic you have discussions
of techne which is the same idea the
whole idea is that Society should be run
like a giant math program
and so Plato said the philosopher king
goes and studies on a mountain for 30
years and learns math and then he comes
back and he impresses upon the city on
the society the mathematical geometrical
principles of an ideal State that's what
the Republic is and then in later books
he says that actually it should just run
me run by an oligarchy that is a secret
society all right so yeah and they have
to lie to the public and and Plato was
famous for eugenics for this idea of you
know keeping the population of real very
sustainable level
um and you you know he even says that
not to feed the the plebees meat they
got to eat rice they got to eat that
sounds familiar yeah I heard that before
but yeah that's Bill Gates's major
pledge wow and what they've been talking
about at Davos
um continue go I can't get the numbers
down everybody's got to be eating some
kibble uh
kibble pretty much that's what they have
us eating dog food dog food is meat no
not not the chinese-made stuff there's
okay you're getting for Atlas no I'm not
getting the Chinese man that's right
good dog food is meat a lot after World
War II they created dry animal food dog
and cat food it used to be all meat and
then they're like we need to meet for
the troops so let's create some new
Pharma thing biopharma I don't know what
is in this bread that they're giving to
cats whether you think that's not
supposed to be fat it's fat because it's
eating bread like and cats can't digest
that stuff yeah the carnivores have you
tried Beyond kibble I've got a new
company called Beyond kibble sorry I
used to uh Plato's like one of my Idols
but I just don't know a lot about this
good and bad in Play-Doh why would you
have an idol that you don't know much
about yo he thought Cloud Schwab was a
nice guy yeah I mean I've always looked
up to the idea of people like because of
platonic love things like that like this
this concept that you can have brotherly
love with humans is strictly platonic
apparently
um so he's done a lot of good but
apparently and I love the idea of him
sitting with Socrates is tripping out
just saying the most crazy stuff and
he's writing it down like yo I'm gonna
this World's Gonna remember this dude so
would you say like Plato is like the the
Founding Father of the of the Illuminati
uh yeah ultimately you're talking about
that Jay-Z thing that music group like
the Illuminati is like a vague
generalized term to talk about a lot of
the powerful people that that kind of
roll things in secret it's it's it's
been popularized by people like Tupac
who've talked about and made songs about
it but it's it's just kind of a name for
the people behind the scenes well funny
you said that because the origin of the
phrase Illuminati which comes out of the
French Revolution illuminated one it's
the illuminated ones and I've just been
reading this history of Byzantium and
the the Cambridge guy is talking about
how when platonism made a Resurgence in
Byzantium right when Byzantium was about
to fall uh they were called the
illuminated ones the Illuminati in
Byzantium the radical plate they were
atheist platonists and then they
influenced the Socialists of the French
Revolution the Jacobins who were the
Illuminati historically speaking is this
like the Hermetic Society too does that
all come from some of them were yeah so
plethon was the Byzantine platonist who
was a hermeticist yeah
um and so it comes up to flash forward
to the future 19 1884 Fabian Society who
are the who's the Fabian Society and how
are they involved so this was created by
uh the Rhodes Milner uh circles uh
namely the Royal Society it's it's a one
of the offshoots of that um Cecil Rhodes
was the diamond De Beers magnate uh
working together with other uh Elite
banking families right and they sort of
set up a model for control that was
modeled on the British East India
Company Cecil Cecil's thing was diamonds
but that gave him the idea from secret
societies like Freemasonry to create his
own society called The Society of the
elect and the plan was originally to
bring America back under the British
Empire
um they didn't really succeed at that
but what they did do was make alliances
with the wealthiest families in the U.S
who were all namely David Rockefeller
for example who were not just influenced
by Von Hayek and Austrian economics
David was actually really influenced by
the Harvard socialist Harold Lasky and
that's what got him into fabianism and
that's why Rockefeller for example was a
big fan of Mao like he wrote editorials
in 1979 New York Times saying that Mao's
experiment was this great thing so the
wealthiest people that you could think
of in America JP Morgan Chase right
they're all funding and supporting
socialism even Brzezinski in between two
ages cites Anthony Sutton who's Anthony
Sutton's famous Professor wrote the book
uh Wall Street the Revolution
and Hitler and uh in Wall Street talking
about the elites funded these groups
right and especially the Bolsheviks and
the Communists and the Chinese
specifically and the Chinese Revolution
that was a major component of the
Rockefeller family that loved everything
that we're doing the whole cultural
revolution they they were loving seeing
all that the one child policy again
spurred on by a lot of these larger
eugenicists that are using China as
their larger playing Ground uh testing
out all this latest and greatest social
credit score technological enslavement
of human beings and a lot of people
believe China is separate and a threat
when in reality China has been taken
over by a lot of the western Elites that
are using it as a model for the world as
cloud Schwab says China is the world
that we want to uh be envisioned sorry I
cut you off because I I just I just I
thought that yeah so the the fabians are
really just the ideologues who took
Marxism and wanted to reform it and
their ideology was was better it was
more successful more useful than
classical Marxism because they were like
oh the proletari will rise up and then
proletariat just cares about going to
lunch and eating their lunch pill right
they're not interested in marxist's
theory right so what the the fabians
realized was that if we combine the
Marxist Revolution with big money we
could have a lot more effect and that's
precisely what they did and so Beatrice
Sydney Webb George Bernard Shaw they
actually got to be really good buddies
with a lot of the American
industrialists and Elites and they
influenced them including Henry Ford to
be into forms of socialism and so that's
why the whole push for the last century
is this sort of technocratic socialist
model so like can we can we just do the
same thing but like any other way can we
like get some prominent
libertarian-minded individuals to come
together to form a secret society that
bestows Liberty and shatters the
shackles and you know what I mean
like they did it can't we be like you
know me and Luke go meet will be like
how can we influence people to believe
in Freedom I guess we're doing it right
now so
yeah well you guys inducted me when I
got here right yeah it was eyes wide
shot ritual downstairs yeah yeah he had
to he had to swear an allegiance to
being a personally personal
responsibility personal responsibility
freedom and liberty so when they
sacrificed and I had to hit three
pointers down there so I didn't realize
yeah and he did and he did when they
started the Federal Reserve in 1913 it
seems like this is part of the movement
to bring the Americans on back under the
British Empire absolutely so and they
did and they did it with the bank of
international settlements in Switzerland
so they're going through Swiss banks so
is the British Empire intricately woven
with the Swiss banks now with a lot of
the stuff Davos is in Switzerland the
bank for international settlements which
is the Central Bank of central banks
it's the Federal Reserve of New York the
bank of England the bank of Australia
all go through the bank for
international settlements in Switzerland
yeah how tight is this that was a even
though that was a post-war creation the
bis they created it post-war to be that
neutral kind of Central Bank of central
banks like you said
um and it's modeled exactly the same way
as the U.S federal reserves model which
is itself modeled on the bank of England
so it was all modeled uh in in regard to
The Milner Fabian circles who instructed
their dude
Colonel Edwin Mandel house who was the
Handler for Woodrow Wilson so that's why
all of this gets pushed under Woodrow
Wilson so the the League of Nations was
created to be that first attempt at
Global government government under the
Wilson Administration right they were
pushing that then that didn't it failed
and so they needed another world war and
then that led to United Nations and it's
exact same people that set that up but
it's set up by the by the same people
setting up the bis yeah and the land
that was donated for the United Nations
was donated by David Rockefeller who of
course played a very key role in setting
up this kind of international
institution that would bring all the
governments together in order to set
some kind of soft form of world
government and when you look at the
United Nations the way it was built a
lot of the kind of weird kind of occult
stuff inside of it it it it it goes
along along with the same kind of larger
principles and ideologies that a lot of
these kind of satanists also kind of
profess and express what caused the
League of Nations to fail
it didn't have any military prowess and
it was at that time they weren't able to
convince Americans to go along with it
so actually Congress didn't go along
with Woodrow Wilson's internationalism
that he was pushing but they did get the
bank pushed at that time right so it
took several more decades to get the U.S
to go along with this stuff and that's
the key role that a lot of the British
intelligence assets played including Ian
Fleming of James Bond Fame so
um William Stevenson of Canada who was
British intelligence in Canada he had an
office in Rockefeller Plaza Noel coward
the author you've probably heard of him
and Ian Fleming were able to convince
the U.S to set up its secret security
establishment 1942 and they put Bill
Donovan as head of that that becomes
eventually the CIA right so that's that
secret establishment it's really just a
private Army The Rockefellers is what it
amounts to do you think this is a bit
more uh anecdotal but do you think that
they were like great your Global powers
that pushed Germany into World War II
and Hitler was kind of like a useful
idiot or did he actually seize control
and just go Rogue no I think that he was
funded by these families and that if you
read there's a whole chapter that
quickly covers it's called the
appeasement plan so the British had a
dual Paul the British had a dual policy
where on the one hand they were secretly
supporting Hitler because they wanted
the war but then they were publicly
opposing him and that's because as
Quigley says and actually the dude from
Stratford agrees with this the the whole
20th century was to exhaust and get rid
of the anglo-american establishments to
main Rivals Russia and the Australian
Empire the 20th century does that
particularly so the first two world wars
get rid of that cold war basically
depletes and gets rid of Russia that was
that key role that Brzezinski played in
getting Russia bogged down in the the
Afghanistan conflict and then they lose
the culture a lot of people need to
understand too that the United States
was very Pro Nazi and private I
shouldn't say the United Country but uh
of the year yeah the the bushes
who was a Senator at the time was
actually uh trialed uh for supporting
the Nazis uh there was also huge
stadiums in Madison Square Garden where
they had full-on Nazi rallies that were
that were filled to capacity there was a
lot of very powerful individuals that
were bankrolling them financing them
many powerful corporations uh you know
corporations like Coca-Cola IBM and of
course a lot of the bigger influence
from Hitler came from a lot of the
Eugenics Rockefeller funded medical
studies and boards that of course he
paid for in finance that essentially
created the theory that Hitler was going
on with his larger uh genocide yeah look
at this look at this these photos from
this is from NPR this is crazy stuff
yeah that's Madison Square Garden
Madison Square Garden Nazi rally in uh
was it 1939. yeah Henry Ford was also
another uh supporter when did the when
did World War II start was 1939 right I
was gonna yeah that's crazy yeah and
then all of a sudden all the banks were
like wait wait we got to stop we gotta
stop we can't support the 1938 Hitler
was Time person of the year he was on
Time Magazine Time Magazine was run by
Henry loose who was calling both I got
uh I went to an antique store a couple
of them uh in West Virginia because
there's tons of people have antiquing
out here and I I was able to buy
hundreds of Life magazine going all the
way back I got I think I have the first
issue actually which was like a couple
hundred bucks I was really excited to
get it and we're gonna be putting at the
new studio like a viewing Library where
you can go back and read all of the
contextual perspectives it was is it is
crazy to read about World War II before
they knew what was going on nuts in one
of one of the magazines they're like the
U.S sent defensive Machinery equipment
to the UK to prevent an invasion and it
basically shows the armaments for D-Day
like we now know the US was sending
weapons so they could storm the beaches
of Normandy back then it was reported
that they were just defending the UK Oh
you mean the news was lying to people in
the military game really well I mean
look I don't expect them to be like
we're gonna invade the whole thing was
subterfuge played on the Germans
essentially so they didn't know when
they were coming or where they're coming
from it really is these these magazines
are incredible to like read history in
the perspective of the day with no
foreknowledge
having the gift of hindsight to read
like it's it's just a crazy thing to
read someone a journalist be so wrong
about it it's part of why we need to
preserve our data and why censorship is
dangerous and why we need like external
sources of data collection because we
need like our our data should be in
orbit in glass in case a meteor
annihilates the surface so that we can
see what the mistakes we made along the
way and all the things like what you're
talking about how we manipulated our
enemies in the past how they can be
manipulating us right now do you think
that when the Soviet Union was falling
apart with this this concerted effort to
make the Russians and the Austrian
Hungarian Empire disappear that when
because I think when they split up the
Soviet Union the oligarchs or whoever
split it up gave the Black Sea to
Ukraine they took it away from Russia
they didn't want them to have
Mediterranean access so was that you
think that was intentional absolutely
That's a classic strategic area Ukraine
is right so uh Hitler had that as a
really important area when he was trying
to you know go against Russia
um but the cold war in my view was was a
managed dialectic ultimately I mean not
saying it didn't I mean my uncle was
like a you know Air Force guy in the
Cold War so I'm not saying that people
didn't do stuff but at a higher level
you know these are the people who wanted
there to be a dialectic between you know
Eastern capital or Western capitalism
and Eastern Soviet black communism to
smash the two together and what you get
out of that is what's called a Third Way
synthesis and even back in the day in
the in like the 30s Burton Russell was
writing in scientific Outlook as a high
level you know Elite planner at the
Royal Society he was writing and saying
that he says quote the experiment in
Russia under Stalin is going great and
you'll find them talking about David
Rockler talks about Mao's you know
experiment these are experiments I think
of Technologies of governance they want
to see how they work I think I think
Nazism was the same thing and so they
they find what works well in what
regions that's why the West is still
promoting you know azerb Italian and
that stuff in Ukraine now right I
thought we're supposed to be against
Nazis right America right but in the
Ukraine it's cool I mean it makes no
sense right but it makes sense right
from a geopolitical strategic standpoint
so absolutely like the the point was to
deplete destroy Russia ultimately for
integrating every everything into a
technocratic order that was the plan 100
years ago what we're seeing now
so yeah it sounds like it was the plan
two thousand years ago with Plato but or
at least he was giving the philosophy
the plan hadn't yeah I think Plato
thought that you could have us like a
city state but I don't know if he
thought like the whole world would come
you know conform to this maybe he
thought that I think later plateness
like in the Middle Ages thought we could
take that model and it actually should
be the whole world I mean you even see
this in enlightenment philosophers like
you know Kant has a whole thing about
how to create a world government so
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time